let's welcome our first guest
she is the vice president of development
and production at marvel new media
and she's the executive producer of
marvel's 616
and marvel's behind the mask sarah amos
thank you so much for joining us today
hey guys thank you so much for having me
i'm really excited to be here
well we are excited to have you here
today can you tell us a little bit about
yourself and what got you started in
filmmaking
i just love storytelling i love picking
a topic or getting to dive
into an area of history or something
that's interesting to me that
perhaps i thought i knew and then
through the process of filmmaking
discover a whole new side of that story
that maybe is unexpected maybe brings
out emotion
maybe inspire someone watching at home
oh that's great
and what led you to marvel new media
specifically i was lucky enough to get
brought on as we were kind of building
up the new media team
to me it just all clicked in exactly the
right way and i was so lucky to to get
to join the team
and really help kind of spearhead a
couple of bigger non-fiction projects
that started to dive more into the
history and the characters and maybe
sides of marvel comics
that people didn't know existed from
movies to documentaries to comics
marvel has told so many groundbreaking
stories over the years
are there any in particular that you've
connected with the most
at the heart of what marvel is it is it
is human stories and it is about our
characters and you can put them through
the ringer so i love
moon girl and devil dinosaur i love
squirrel girl
i think anyone who wants some humor in
their comics is yeah see you're in
the one that i'm absolutely obsessed
with is everything x-men
there's not a single x-men comic that
comes out these days that i'm not
giddy to pick up you helped bring some
amazing non-fiction marvel stories of
disney plus what made you want to bring
people behind the scenes and what do you
hope they discover there
my hope is that everyone takes away
something a little different right i
think the beauty of marvel
is that there is a comic book or
character for everyone
right you can love drama or comedy or
action adventure and you can find the
thing that you connect with and we tried
to do the same thing with 616
getting to learn more about the history
of kind of how marvel comics came to be
and maybe some unsung heroes that you
hadn't heard of before
getting to watch a comic book get made
we actually follow one of our amazing
writers dan slock and you get to see the
artists at work
to see the way our characters and our
stories can really affect people's lives
all of those are kind of real human
connection and and real life lessons
and kind of inspirations that i i hope
people get to enjoy and experience when
they watch the series
i loved episode 2 of marvel's 616 higher
further faster because it breaks down
the misconception
that comics are only created by men
foreman
so how did it feel to spotlight all of
these amazing women behind marvel comics
that episode is so special to us
gillian jacobs came on really early into
the series
and she has a real passion and a
dedication to help
telling the stories of women who were
involved in industries
that maybe predominantly get seen as
as male dominated industries i think for
me
just getting to learn myself and become
educated about these uh
incredible creators and the journey for
women
throughout marvel comics was really one
of the best things
and seeing the the future of where
marvel comics is going and
the way that we are expanding to include
more voices
and to make sure all points of view are
represented
and to hopefully put out a product that
young girls can pick up
or read on their phones and say hey i
see myself in that
and this inspires me to want to be a
part of that industry one day
like that's the best thing to get to do
yeah it's really empowering because
i feel like shows like this are going to
make
such a massive probably already are
making such a massive impact
on both boys and girls because just five
years ago
me wearing this shirt would get me
questioned you're a fake geek girl
you're not really you don't read the
comics you don't know what you're
talking about you're just wearing a
shirt because you think it's cool
and i think with you know shows like
marvel 616
audiences get to see oh there are
women lots of women behind some of my
favorite characters and stories and
and and people of color just an array of
of people that i think
the average person doesn't expect it's
it's a it's a thing of
it's only guys the larger media
perception
has been wrong for a long time and it is
assumed that the fan base only looked
like
one type of person and that has not been
the case
a lot of the most die-hard fans i know
of marvel comics are women of color
and like they can throw down way more
facts and information
than a lot of what people would consider
to be traditional fans so i do think
it's great
just to get to showcase the wide array
of marvel fans that really are
out there and kind of be like hey guys
this is actually something that everyone
can be a part of
marvel speaks to such a wide range of
ages and gender tell us why you think
it's important to make these stories so
accessible
marvel can be very daunting to people if
you haven't read
every captain america run for the last
40 years
how am i going to know where to even
begin and so we did try to
tell stories that yes were about our
characters and our legacy
but not necessarily just about
the comics themselves there is a larger
element of storytelling that goes on at
marvel and there is a larger
message that a lot of times we are
trying to make sure is encapsulated
in the brand and in what we do and and i
do think that there are things that
that people can connect with even if
comics
and superheroes aren't their thing what
advice do you have
for future creators be honest with who
you
are and and know your own truth
and what you want to take from
from that and put into your work and
eventually you will connect with the
person
that sees your truth the same way you do
and will help
you get it to a larger audience know who
you are believe in who you
are and and then just have the hard work
ethic
and the determination to see that
through it's been
amazing having you sarah thank you so
much for joining us today
well thank you guys thank you for having
me it's always fun to to get to come and
and meet new people
and talk about things i like so please
yes watch
marvel 616 and behind the mask on disney
[Music]
plus
[Music]
you